ça bouge nous sommes à clécy pour vous
parler de théâtre ce soir si quelqu'un a
quelque chose à dire sur le théâtre ce
soir qu'on me le dise personne manon
père trouve un nom ce soir théâtre au
théâtre ce soir à clécy une générale on
y met du volume on y met du théâtre ça
roule et kaki théâtre renaud ça
m'arrange vous êtes le metteur en scène
cette pièce s'appelle donc
qu'importe le flocon nous on en a de la
neige nous voilà vous êtes metteur en
scène guy lacombe d'acteurs se ressent
sur la scène ici sur la scène il y aura
au maximum neuf personnes mais nous
sommes douze acteurs parce que certains
groupes sont doublés d'accord en tant
que metteur en scène il est dur mais les
commandes ça va il est gentil et
j'entends dire où ça tu feras pas là tu
sais quand tu frappes à la foire du
frappe à la porte
qu un point final on est une troupe
d'amis on est une troupe qui ne se prend
pas au sérieux mais qui est sérieuse
parce qu'on veut absolument proposer à
nos spectateurs un spectacle de qualité
c'est ça la vraie vie rencontrer des
gens nouveaux que la vie nous présente
et que jamais nous n'aurions rencontrer
dans des conditions normales la neige
c'est magique c'est notre quatorzième
pièce 14e pièces et moi en tant que
metteur en scène c'est la 5ème choc
était pire que je ne pensais tu es marié
pour la du trapel oui je me souviens je
suis mariée ça me revient dans ma
chambre mon vieux dindar question quel
est le défaut majeur du théâtre amateur
selon vous qu'est ce qu'il faut corriger
en premier qu'est ce qu'il faut corriger
en premiers mois je la première chose
qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
d'apprendre son texte plus en amour ça
je serais d'accord et si je peux me
permettre parce que il faut pouvoir se
libérer du texte
qu'apporte le elorn flocons flocons
flocons là où ça bouge nous sommes à
l'artothèque de caen pour vous parler
d'une exposition qui débute samedi et
dont l'intitulé d'un petit peu déroutant
ensemble non le chrome mais rossé par
tête d'éléphant
je suis le type qui voulait faire un
monochrome finalement qui a mis pas mal
de couleur dedans et qui a compensé en
rajoutant des tête d'éléphant le fait
que qui est de la couleur sur un
monochrome voyez moi je suis dans le
code la peinture il ya une surface plate
plane découpé avec voilà parfois du
graphisme parfois si parfois ça de la
couleur des surfaces donc là bon oui
parfois la touche est très épaisse
regarder van gogh comme ses épais et
bien là c'est vraiment super et paix et
je me suis dit faisons comme s'il y
avait un mauvais réglage je règle avec
un tournevis pouvoir tout est sorti d'un
côté trop et de l'autre côté chez les
tables sont pleins
moi je fabrique des jeux fabrique des
hypothèses ça c'est une hypothèse il y
en a d'autres et ensuite j'espère que
dans ces hypothèses elles vont produire
quelque chose qui m'échappe et que ça va
finalement les gens vont arriver c'est
pas mal beau tableau j'aime bien j'aime
bien les couleurs dire que tout ce
discours ne servent à rien vous voyez le
bien voilà cette exposition au palais
ducal à l'artothèque de caen du 15
janvier au 26 mars s'appelle ensemble
non monochrome mais rehaussé par tête
d'éléphant héros du long sans doute
et si on se faisait un petit ciné
concert charlot fait le pitre sous la
musique de l'orchestré de normandie
créée exprès pour vous par cyrine au
fort d'abord c'est de faire redécouvrir
un petit peu ce qui se faisait à
l'époque
à l'époque les films étaient souvent
accompagnés par un piano soi qui est
improvisé soit tu fais de la musique
ensuite la musique de chant ensuite ce
qu'on peut appeler ici n'est concernée
avec un orchestre donc d'abord c'est un
retour aux sources est vrai que les
jeunes générations connaissent pas
forcément les films de chaplin moi je
les fais découvrir à mes enfants qui ne
connaissait pas le nom et qui part à ma
grande surprise mais ont adoré ça et
maintenant leurs regards de tous c'est
pour les grands et donc les petits à
partir de 3 ans profitez-en
l' orchestre tourner jusqu'au 31 janvier
aéroville en fleurs falaise d'amis ni et
cabourg
m
je ne